guys so at some point you wake up as a
data scientist you wonder what are we
doing and there is lots of different
schools out there nowadays and you
sometimes then get to the conclusion
that if you're doing things with data
there tend to be these three schools of
doing things there's these people that
people call for cuentas there's these
people that people call beijing's and
there's these people they call
themselves machine learning specialists
if you've gone through a Dutch college
then you'll probably be taught that if
you did something in computer science
you've probably done that and I always
found that this Bayesian thing is
something we don't really do too much in
Europe and all the cool things I see
online always happen in the US so I
figured it might be fun to do a small
talk on that because thinking like a
Bayesian does feel like you can always
apply some duct tape to wherever you're
doing with data this is gonna be a
little bit math heavy so I'm gonna give
you guys a couple of textbook examples
introduce the idea of days I'm gonna
show you some moments when doing some
Bayesian statistics really shines I'm
gonna introduce how to do publicity
graphical modeling in Python as well
I'll even give an explanation of how you
can use Bayesian statistics to do Oh RI
algorithms and then at the end I'm gonna
show you guys a good algorithm to
predict the heroes of the storm match
outcomes so textbook Bayes rule
probability theory is kind of nice
because if you think about it
Laplace summed it up quite nicely and
the theory of probabilities is basically
just common sense reduce the calculus if
you want to talk about the likelihood of
something happening probability theory
really helps you quantify it in the most
exact way that there is which also means
that if you just make a couple of
assumptions you can leave the rest of
probability theory and you will have
your model so this is what bass rule
looks like this is sort of probability
101 I guess but the best way to explain
it so there are two events and suppose I
know something of one event let's call
that event B then I might have a
different belief on what event a might
be and if I want to know something about
a and I know B then I can use Bayes rule
to do some inference simple example
suppose that I have a couple of dice if
I have one die then my belief of how
many eyes I get to see is different than
if I have two dice so one way of looking
at it and my belief over the number the
sum of the eyes that I see depends on
the number of dice
I'm rolling in this case the this would
be the probability of eyes given the
number of dice you can also look at it
the other way suppose I want to know the
probability of the number of dice that
I've cast given the number of eyes then
instead of looking at it from this
direction you would simply look at it
from this direction that's sort of the
nice thing about inference if I know PE
given D then I can infer what PD given
you might be that's sort of the cool
trick and I guess a better example of
that would be just the textbook example
so suppose there's an epidemic and the
person has a probability to have a
certain disease and then the authorities
decide to test the population but the
test is not entirely reliable so the
test generally gives 110 people positive
result but if you took a test and it has
a positive result there's a very likely
situation that you might actually have
the original disease so then as a you
know a proper college student and you're
doing something with a textbook you
would just fill in this formula and a
number would pop out and there's again
some inference so if I didn't know what
the result of the test was this would
have been the probability that you
actually had the disease but given that
I now know that you took this test I can
apply the probability statistics that I
know and come to it probability but we
kind of know a bit more so this is if
this is a situation and I know only
these three probabilities I might
actually be able to figure out some
other useful metrics I will try to keep
the math light but hopefully this isn't
such a weird thing to assume from you
guys if I know the probability of T so
there's a probability that the test came
out positive then I can split that up
into two situations namely the tests
came up positive and you had the disease
and the test came out positive but you
didn't have a disease and then I can
sort of apply a version of Bayes rule
again to say all but the probability of
that you have the disease and that the
test came out positive that can be very
written like so and again then they can
fill the numbers in again and suddenly
even though I just calculated the
probability that you have the disease
when you took the test and now also know
the probability of the test comes out
positive if you don't have the disease
what else can we know well
do a bunch of math but you can then also
infer it's a probability of two tests
come out positive note that in order for
that to do I need the probability that
the test comes out positive even though
if I don't have a disease this is a lot
of math so we don't like looking at this
maybe look let's look at it from a more
simple way how about we just turn it
into a graph instead so in a simple
situation if I if you have the disease
the test result is basically if
influence now I can take another test
and this is the same representation the
graphical version of it and the cool
thing is the result of this test is only
influenced by whether or not you have
the disease
so given if I'm having the disease or
not that's the only thing that
influenced the test so then I can
calculate hey what's the probability
that I have two disease given these two
tests and I'm still just applying
probability theory but even though in
the beginning I only really knew stuff
about this I can infer this and if I do
another test I can infer that as well
and that's kind of it so this is sort of
the cool thing about probability theory
you know that these values are correct
because it's just common sense because
it's the loss of probability that we're
hearing here so even though if I only
know about you did this one test and
then say something about what unless you
have the disease I can infer what it
means if you maybe do two tests and
because it's probability so this is sort
of a probabilistic system if you will I
can even go and step further and say
well suppose that I don't know whether
or not you have the disease and I know
that you took test 1 and test 3 what do
I then know about the outcome of test 2
that is also a situation where you don't
beforehand know anything about your
training data but you can infer the rest
so this is this aspect of we only put a
little bit of knowledge in and the rest
is done through probablistic inference
as a powerful thing because via Bayes
rule we can basically infer information
about the probability of you having the
disease that you took more tests even
though we initially only knew about the
probability of you getting a positive
test result given that you have the
disease and the trick here is that we
clearly defined our uncertainty that we
have and we can infer the rest fire
probability theory in this case the main
Chi was that realizing that the tests
are independent of one another
given that I has a disease the test role
independent which means they can think
according to this structure and know
this that's also kind of interesting
suppose that this is an online system
and I'm predicting whether or not you
have the disease then I suddenly have a
robust model that given different forms
of input it is the same system that's
performing the prediction so a
prediction time I can have different
amounts of data known to me and still be
able to make a good prediction come out
in my experience most random forced
packages and neural networks don't have
this property that if there is a value
missing say there's a null somewhere a
psychic learn will give you an error so
that's interesting what else could we do
with this idea well I like this
graphical representation because it
basically allows me to put some domain
knowledge in a system and then lets me
infer the rest so people again give that
a name they call them probablistic
graphical models so let's think of a
published graphical model and this will
be a silly example but it's to drive the
point across so let's say I have
something my knowledge and I I'm gonna
think about a good graph like structure
that would describes a situation at hand
so let's create one with this library
called pomegranate it's a library I
found it's fairly new but it does
exactly what I wanted to do so let's
assume that we want to know if today's
weather is predicted correctly and let's
say that there are three broadcasters
we've got Alice she's super accurate
we've got Bob he's downright terrible
and then we have Claire and she's all
right so if I know who's doing the
prediction that I can infer something
about what the weather is gonna be is
the weather's gonna be predicted
correctly today this is not necessarily
something that happens in your life but
serves a purpose as an example here but
suppose I know more suppose that I also
know that alice is more of a weekday
kind of person and Bob is a little bit
more of a weekend type of person and
Claire kind of does both let's maybe
because Claire's some form of in turn
she's the backup of the two and you'll
notice that given it's a weekday than a
70% chance that it's Alice 10% that is
Bob and 20% that is Claire so these
probabilities sum up 200 so given what
day of the week
I know something about who's going to be
predicting give
whose predicting I know something about
that's gonna be correct let's say and
this is actually not that unlikely let's
say that it is if it's a weekend is
actually sunny this app happens a lot in
real life because if it's weekends
there's less car about less cars means
less pollution less pollution means less
clouds let's say something like that
again I'm not arguing that this is the
real world but I am arguing suppose we
had this situation I could model it like
this and you can already imagine how
useful this might be if I because I can
ask all sorts of questions to this
system suppose the only thing that I
know is this that Claire is doing the
prediction today then I know something
about this situation but also because I
know that if Claire is doing the
predicting today it's probably gonna be
a weekday and I also know that it's kind
of likely it's not gonna be sunny today
so you can see that from this system if
I have only one input it can deal with
it if I have two inputs it can equally
deal with it that's a nice property
another thing to notice is that if I
know P in this example so I know the
person who's doing the predicting then
knowing something about the day of the
week will not have any more influence on
whether or not it was correct this is
between D and C henceforth if I know
this D will not be having any influence
on C anymore also this is a property
that I'd like and this is also thing
that it's very hard to model with a
random forest or a neural network if you
will so what the code of this looked
like well you need the probabilities
beforehand but basically if you want to
use Palmgren out what you would do is
you would say hey import palm granada's
peak PQ for some sort of spelling error
on my side and you would then say well
the probability of a weekend is well two
out of seven let's say probability for
weekdays five out of seven I'm assuming
that the weather channel is always on
and then I can define this conditional
probability table where I basically say
hey given that it's a weekday - probably
if it being Alice is such-and-such and
that's how we define it once you've done
that you can create a graph where you
say hey I've defined all these variables
so I could say I have a state for day of
the week I've state for who and its
state for sunny and this is and then you
make this grow
appear so we have a network we say hey
whether day of the week does the thing
we want to predict these are the states
these are the states have defined
earlier I make a list put all the states
in there and then I put all these
transitions in and you'll notice at the
top of the chain we have the day of the
week which is linked to s2 which is the
who David week says something about who
they the week says something about sunny
and who says something about correct
then you tell the network to go bake
itself and once the network is baked you
can ask it questions so you can say
suppose do all of your inference and
let's say that the person afflicting is
Alice well then I'm pretty sure that the
person who's predicting is indeed Alice
there's probability of one but what the
network will then do is it will all the
inference for you to then say something
about where that's gonna be sunny where
that's gonna be correct and whether or
not you're doing something in the
weekday or in the weekend you'll notice
that this is the probability that I put
in myself given that alice is the person
is doing the predicting this is what
will come out that's the arrow you've
defined specifically the other two
values are inferred similar to what I
did with the example with the diseases
doing more tests and doing inference
with math this library is able to do
that for you and again I put only one
thing in suppose I put Bob in well we
Bob was downright terrible so not only
is the prediction kind of worse but it's
also less sunny one thing we do kind of
like is that immediately if it does
become much more likely the weekend so
that's a nice property we can put to
stuff in so we could say yeah it's the
weekend and Bob is doing the predicting
well and suddenly you know these values
are the values I put in but again this
is an example I'm putting two things in
and the system can then infer
information about the other two things
nice property me gusta I like this now
let's say that the weather was predicted
correctly so this is the thing that
surprises a lot of people because if you
look at this it's see you almost get
implied that I have to put this in and
then this can come out but as I
explained before if I know the weather
was predicted correctly that says
something about who did the predicting
which in turn says something about what
day the week it might be which in turn
says something about where that's gonna
be sunny so if I plug in hey today was a
career
today well you know it's probably Alice
now this is great and it's probably
sunny because Alice says something would
date a week which says something about
etc so take that venom forest this is
these are cool properties the main
downside of doing this of course is that
I as a business professional have to
come with the idea this is a sensible
way to model things however what I get
back for it is a very very flexible
model that can deal with missing data at
prediction time it could even deal with
missing data at learning time by the way
suppose that for some rows of my data
set when I'm trying to learn this when
I'm trying to learn these probabilities
that is the probabilities that I would
plug in to this conditional table if I
have a couple of rows that's says
something about the relationship between
D and s but in the same row I have
nothing about this then I can still make
this relationship sophistical e stronger
it gives me more certainty of the
relationship between d NS even though I
don't know anything about the
relationship between PD and C at
learning time I will need some rows of
course that connect everything but if I
only but if say this bit is very strong
and that but is very strong and this bit
is very weak I could still do influence
so not only a prediction time but also
at learning time I have a systematic way
of dealing with missing data and I'm
adhering to all the rules of probability
which have tons and tons of benefits so
these types of malls are very powerful
and flexible one of his most powerful
features is that it can handle missing
data at prediction time the example that
I've given only handles discrete models
also the Palmgren library in general
only deals with discrete probability
values at the moment but mathematically
you know you can also use continuous
distributions there's no real reason why
that should not work coding these things
are a bit harder so pong grenades great
but if you want to do something with
both discrete and continuous it becomes
a little bit harder and then you might
want to think about sampling because
technically what you could also do is
you could just say hey if this is the
parent that I want how about I just
create a giant pandas dataframe millions
of rows at first i generate this column
D and we knew something about how often
it's gonna be a weekend and how awful is
gonna be day of the week and I'm going
to create a new column called P which
has a sort of if statement if
has this value then P is generated
according to this process and you repeat
then you got this data frame but you can
basically ask the same questions to it's
just a group by in the filter and then a
summarization at the end so this feels
kind of I'm not say I wasn't call this
super Bayesian but the probabilistic
thinking eared has health so let's look
at an example where Bayesian thinking
really shines so in Holland we have
these walls in our garden and basically
what can happen is you can sit in your
garden and only very tall people stick
above the wall so if I'm sitting and I'm
collecting data as I am as a data
scientist always collecting you know so
then I know that what I'm measuring is
in principle biased data so given that
I'm measuring bias data I know how it's
biased cuz I know the height of my own
wall what can I do to do inference on
the actual average height of everyone if
I know that I only measure people above
a certain height and I will leave you to
think about that for about 10 seconds
and you may realize that this is a
tricky problem so I know that I have a
biased data set I don't know anything
about the total population and I have to
infer something about the total
population given some biased data set
and the example that I then came up with
this let's say you have a call center
and I'm interested in knowing how long
people wait in line for this call center
and suppose we only mention people that
have been waiting for a very long time
because that's when we start to complain
and let's assume that everyone who has
been waiting for longer than say M
minutes they all start to complain and
everyone below doesn't complain it's a
bit also not the most realistic example
but it's meant to drive the point home
also I know nothing about the total
population this is the only thing that I
actually know because we're going to
model a waiting time it seems sensible
that we'll do it with an exponential
distribution to look at the intermediate
waiting time between people and let's
say I'm interested in figuring out what
lambda is now if I know lambda then I
know something about you know how long
it's going to be taking for you to get
handled however I'm interested in
finding lambda the show how they spinner
the function works so basically a higher
value of lambda means that you haven't
with a thicker tail so higher lambda
longer waiting times okay base comes to
the rescue them and so then basically
I'm writing down what I want to know
given my bias dataset I want to know the
best value for lambda bass rule well you
know this is the probability that the
bias dataset comes from this value of
lambda this is what they know beforehand
about this value of lambda and this is
the process of how the data gets
generated but if I think about it
I can you know I don't really care about
this one because in the end I'm
interested in finding the largest lambda
which means that if it's proportional I
can also just focus on this it to be
fine and yeah the entire dataset because
this is a likelihood of like from a
proper distribution of probability I
could basically say well the likely of
getting the entire dataset given lambda
is just multiplying the likelihood that
I have gotten one point from the dataset
and just multiply all the points
together suddenly it becomes kind of
obvious how to do this Bayes rule
inspired me towards a solution here so
again given a certain lambda I know the
probability of the likelihood I should
say of X i given lambda given by
function like this and the only thing I
have to now compensate for is that I
only measure people here so the trick
you would then do is you would say okay
this has to be a property distribution
henceforth I need to normalize something
and I can ignore everything here so all
the extras always fall in here so then
what you do is you normalize it which is
basically an integral way say hey take
the density distribution from M and I
have this normalizing constant chug it
in and that way this will be a proper
distribution again and to sort of show
how you would do that in Python you make
these two functions I'll not go too much
in depth and how they work because I
have pretty pictures that's always
better so given a certain M these are
the distributions that you would have
for different lambdas and if you would
then have different M's with the same
lambda it would look like this and it
functions that I've just shown you real
quick which I didn't explain generate
this and so again given a certain lambda
and a
I have a point say at X equals 10 this
would be the likely I would have and I
can do the same for all the things in my
dataset now here I combined it all again
the main thing to remember is I'm
multiplying things here and what you
then see is boom given a certain data
set so suppose I have M is equal to 4
and I have 7 6 & 8 then this is the
posterior likelihood of what lambda
might be so this looks cool but to
convince you how about I just show you a
demonstration where I know lambda
beforehand so let's just generate a data
ourselves so let's say that M is equal
to 6 the 2 lambda is equal to 1 I'm
generating some data and what I'll then
do is I'm going to filter some data out
if it's lower than M and we're gonna do
this a bunch of times and see what
happens if I have more data in my
dataset so let's say that I only have 6
comma 0 9 and 6 for my 3/8 and again M
is equal to 6 here so I only have two
data points and this is what I then know
what I think about lambda given these
two data points this is everything I
know and the true value is equal to 1 so
after 2 data points you know I'm not
entirely in the 1 region so I could be
doing better you should be the best way
to go about this is just get more deep
and you know we got now six data points
and already we see it's venturing to or
if it's true value very quickly this is
kind of nice and I'm also not excluding
yet that it might be 2 there I'm not
entirely certain about my lambda but my
belief is updated so let's now say M is
equal to 2 and lambda is equal to 1 and
I'm doing this so I'll have more data
points to my sample and now suddenly it
really is gonna start getting close to 1
so as I get more data I'm able to update
my belief accordingly and the way that I
got here is just by applying probability
theory and by being reminded by Bayes
rule which basically then stated well if
you want to do this you just follow
through hmm so thinking really helped in
this problem and with my normal way of
textbook statistics this might have been
hard another example so crazy crazy
science direction you could go ahead and
do a master's in operations research
it's a very interesting topic now let's
pick a very silly optimization task
suppose that I have
a 1x1 square and in this 1x1 square I
have I'm gonna create a triangle and
it's of my interest that I'm creating a
triangle as big as possible now because
we're all intelligent humans we know
that the best triangle should be one
point in one corner the other point of
the other and something on the other
side and that's the biggest triangle we
can get but the algorithm would have to
figure this out by itself so how about
we just try out a bunch of stuff there's
this function called shoelace which is
on the ipython notebook but I didn't
care about the funding in here basically
what it does is given six points namely
X 1 X 2 X 3 y 1 y 2 y 3 to define all
the coordinates then I can calculate
what the area would look like so this is
a distribution of the area given random
points I'm drawing random points in the
1x1 square this what the area would look
like so this is the highest value
possible which we never sample but we
sample a lot of small triangles that's
that's the idea so this sort of
generating process something which
suggests the city this is what it looks
like
so I know something about the
probability distribution of a a being
the area and X being the the coordinates
of the triangles that I measure let's
now try to turn that on top of his head
so let's say I'm sampling lots of these
data points and I can at some point say
how about after I've sampled us of data
points I just take the points where the
area is above a certain threshold then I
should get a different probability
density distribution something that
generates X and you know we can pick em
in such a way that we do this updating
ly so how about we pick M to be like to
half like the the median value so all
the points so all the areas that are
higher than the median those are the
points of interest and I want to know
what the distribution looks like
so now scikit-learn becomes interesting
again because scikit-learn has a kernel
density estimator so what you can do is
you can generate all these points and
then try to fit a density on top of it
and then try to infer what it would look
like if I were to sample triangles that
were large and again is there still a
random process but just by sampling a
bit and using a bit of Bayesian
inspiration I'm suddenly learning that
this is X 1 this X 2 and X 3 so
coordinate for the first coordinate will
be combined by combining y1 and x1 and
suddenly all the Y's together it does
seem like if I want to have big areas it
will be a good idea to keep y1 and y2
far away from each other that's
something that I'm learning from
sampling the same thing holds for X by
the way let's maybe just zoom in on that
so this is could be this is these are
the X values but for the Y values you
get something similar so it makes sense
everyone have a big triangle the sample
points far away from one another that's
all something you see from the one
dimensional Instagram now these are
actually more interesting this is where
the X's in the Y's combine and then
suddenly you kind of realize well you
know the difference between x and y kind
of works a little bit differently if a
y-value is low then the x value can
actually quite be quite big that's fine
or they can be close to one another you
can look at this all for a long while
but the main conclusion is I now have a
new density distribution I can sample
from so this is these are larger
triangles and I have a density
distribution to sample from so where
before I was sampling this completely
randomly by then saying hey I want to
sample from larger triangles I'm
suddenly sampling from this all of my
triangles that I've sampled are larger
and you know I can again cut and repeat
cut and repeat and suddenly through
Bayes rule I've come to some genetic
algorithm genetic algorithms work in a
very similar fashion also random search
also put a little bit of bias in the
difference being here I'm doing it
rather more probabilistic alee so even
in the science of operations research
I'm able to be better at what I do by
once in a while reminding myself that
Bayes rule is a thing and a couple of
you know next steps if you're interested
in doing something like this this works
for all sorts of search spaces and it's
actually kind of nice that you can infer
statistic properties from the
estimations that you get so from the
solution that you get to your problem so
we can repeat the same idea until some
form of conversions occurs so note that
M can be chosen automatically so for
example pick M to be the average area
that you found from the original sample
but the cool bonus again is that we can
use inference on our simulated data to
learn more about the nature of our
optimization problem and you should
notice something very similar happening
with cinetic algorithms
as well so so often when I give these
talks like last year I did a talk on
World of Warcraft I noticed that half
the crowd came because they wanted to
know more about World of Warcraft and
the other half of the crowd were
interested in data analysis now does
anyone know this game so this is heroes
of the storm is sort of the the new
benchmark uber game from Blizzard and
the way that it works you have all these
games like World of Warcraft and they
have sort of these hero characters in
their story and in this game they take
all the characters from all the
universes and it lets you play with it
so for example you can play with a team
that has Illidan the betrayer and I
don't know matter in the dwarf and some
swamp creature and whatnot but the
interesting characteristic of this game
is you basically have to get the two two
teams competing and what's against one
another and one team has to pick five
characters from the entire set and so
that's the other team can I predict who
wins based on the choice of characters
because I'm assuming that there is some
form of rock-paper-scissors element in
this game reason being in this game
there are different roles that you could
play so for example you have the healer
you have the assassin you have got
you've got the Buffy warrior and you've
got support characters and whatnot so it
might be the case that if you've got all
healers that your team's not gonna be
doing too well against all assassins so
camis advisors some algorithm that is
able to recognize this and you know
gaming communities tend to be awesome so
if you go on Reddit you're able to
download a data set which has like half
a million games in it with lots of sort
of things you could infer so can we
predict game outcomes and there's a bit
of a problem you know I have half a
million games in my data set let's think
about the search space so if there are n
heroes my team can pick a combination of
n times n minus 1 times n must minus 2
times n minus 3 times n minus 4 that's
the search pace of characters that this
team could pick now the opponent's team
also has that search space you have to
multiply everything together so you
quickly kind of come to the conclusion
that the search space might be big given
a slightly bigger number of Heroes this
is a big search space in fact even if I
don't if I only have six heroes I might
only have one allocation in my data set
if I only have six and in real life I
have about 36 so the search space is
insane for every possible game that
might have happened I will not have a
data point that's simply the case
especially because when I had the data
said it was like five months ago and
nowadays they've even added more heroes
to this game so this is fast becoming
harder and harder so you know any random
force algorithms gonna give him the
middle finger because you know this data
said it's too sparse it cannot do
anything with it I think yeah so I
basically have 72 columns in this case
because I'm going for the 36 version of
it and out of these 72 columns only ten
are filled in and it'll be just ones and
zeros so I have a prior that even a
random force or a deep neural net will
have a bit of trouble with this simply
cause of the sparsity these models would
work much better if I had much more data
so instead of trying hard to create
features myself that might help the
performance let's use a bit of domain
knowledge to help us out and let's try
to take a probabilistic approach which
you know might feel a bit Bayesian if
you will
ten minutes got it so this is team B and
Team B has five heroes and the ordering
here does not matter but there's five
heroes then here I've got Team A and
hazel we also have five heroes also the
ordering doesn't matter and I want to
get from these heroes from this team
there's some sort of prediction so I
have to fill in a gap there with
something sensible how about I take this
hero and that hero and I combine them
over there I'm gonna do something with
them but the idea is to just say hey
let's look at all the combinations of
all these heroes and then for every
combination do something inference see
over here and then from all of these
nodes we can combine and do something
interesting in fancy at P so what that
would look like this you know okay so I
could have drawn this better let's use a
different type of notation so this this
is what I'm trying to do but let's use
this notation instead people tend to
call this plate notation but the idea
would be I have a team a of a team be
I'm taking all the combinations of
heroes I'm putting that in some form of
plate and for every combination it's
gonna go to some predictor
is this looking like a neural net now is
this a spacian surely so yeah this
approach might work so what I can then
do is if I really want to go
probabilistic how about I know how often
team a1 with this combination often this
hero versus this arrow I know the ratio
of wins so how often that this hero win
versus that hero and that search space
is actually quite a lot smaller that's
just n times n so I will have data quite
a lot of data actually for every single
node here all right so what you would
then do you would be able to get all
these beta distributions and you can
draw them for the entire team I could
then combine them this is a gift I'm
gonna let it run for a couple of times
so don't worry and we're gonna just get
this light real quick but for every
single node that you saw before I'm
generating a bit sort of a distribution
of what I think will happen in the game
outcome that's my belief on which team
might win and given that all of these
are beta distributions you can just
combine them all so the thin lines are
all the smaller nodes and the thick
black bond would be the big node P where
I'm combining stuff and here I'm doing
an insert of a pro ballistic way but to
be honest I can also just regard this if
I'm turning this into a probability of
some source like a ratio of who might
win and I can also see this as a tactic
for feature generation and then okay
let's just put in there all Network
behind that that might also just go
ahead and work at this we're on the
topic since we're thinking this way I
mean this tactic sort of works and I
guess if you're looking at the X values
in the outcome because they will change
up a bit what you will notice is that
it's not like I have hugely
discriminative features at this moment
moment but then again this is a highly
optimized game for balance there's like
a team of very smart people who work for
Blizzard we try to ensure that every
single game that's played has players
that are equally likely to as a team to
win so if I'm able to find any type of
you know a game in balance that already
would be a huge profit even if it's like
only 5% or so how about I go a step
further so before this was the graph
where I would look at like one guy from
team one and one guy from Team B how
about I take two guys from Team A and
two guys from Team B and surely per
bucket here I would have less but I
would have
not more nodes and I can give that to P
so also this might feel a bit like a you
know neural network or whatnot
but the idea is I'm doing feature
engineering from something that makes
sense probabilistic aliy to reduce the
complexity and this turns out to be a
computationally less intensive tactic
and if we're at it okay let's just make
a deep Bayesian sort of convolution in
Samba you totally can there's nothing
that's stopping you so we take the team
one and Team two we have all of these
nodes that goes to some form of
predictor we have other nodes that goes
to another form of predictor and these
two can go to another predictor node
it's kind of like a Bayesian way of
doing a neural network in a way right
and being careful with you know people
might say that's not entirely true which
they would be correct but this is this
is a sound tactic because I can actually
still understand what is happening here
I can look at this graph and assign a
form of interpretation to whatever is
the outcome of these nodes it's a nice
property as well also suppose I only
know about three people from this team
like I'm still infer the rest also
something I like do that with your
neural network so okay so this was
hopefully I've inspired you guys to sort
of forgive this Bayesian school a chance
but it doesn't it still confuses a whole
lot of people because professionals as
well as students as well as sort of
professors at universities all that
suggests to me that this way if
probabilistic thinking comes across as
very new if not super different and the
reason is I'm never using you know
confidence intervals I'm not using
p-values whenever I'm doing a regression
or something like that
I have probabilities but I'm not really
worried about p-values from tables or
anything I've so far never said anything
about statistical significance and I've
not done a hypothesis test so people
always ask the hey can you explain that
what's up with that and you often get
into this discussion of what the
difference is between a Bayesian and a
frequentist so how about I just give my
summary of that all models are wrong
period
Oh models are super wrong some models
however are useful and you kind of have
to wonder to yourself
where do I draw the line for what I tend
to think is useful are you unsure about
the data and you're trying to find the
best single estimator to summarize this
that's a tactic I guess I would call
that for cuentas
are you unsure about the model and do
you accept the data to be the only truth
that you have and are you gonna assign
some certainty in your model I guess I
would call it Bayesian or are you
willing to ignore all uncertainties when
you have a black box that performs very
well against a couple of test sets these
are the three schools in the best
example I could think of was a panda
when I came up with this example I
thought what's McKinney was gonna be
here so I figured talking about pandas
might be nice so let's say that I'm
touring his image of a panda and I want
to have a model describes this Panda is
camera what I would then do is I would
load this in and I would you know check
every single pixel value a pixel value
that has a low value let's just call
that black a pixel valid as a high value
upper limit to one let's call that gray
what I can do as a if I were saying for
Quinn cyst and I'm taking a very harsh
example here and some of the points you
can actually take serious so please
don't read too much about them but if
I'm worried for Quintus my conclusions
would be hey on average a panda is gray
which it is which is completely fine
on average a human being has one
testicle and perhaps one breast I still
don't think that there are many people
who you know are like that and what you
then would do is you would say okay and
if we want to figure out if something is
a panda how about we say this is the
maximum likelihood estimation and I know
the visits the mean and I know the
variance so I can do some confidence
interval around this and then as a
Requin test in this silly example you
may come to the conclusion that a panda
can be 1.5 white so the odds if you're
doing in my experience at least the odds
of something correct happening is while
doing four cuentas statistics are good
just the goods are a bit odd sometimes
if you're a Bayesian I guess my
definition of a Bayesian at least you
would say well my model has a bit of
uncertainty in it I don't have one
maximum likelihood estimator for what a
panda is what I do think is that if I
want to describe a panda it seems
sensible to say that there they seem to
be kind of white not really great and
very black and to be honest I think the
fact that you can say it's really not
great that's a characteristic of a panda
it's black and white it's not gray it
seems like a very sensible way of
thinking about a panda and I guess the
machine learning community would be fine
or saying something like this so dude I
have awesome test set performance I
don't know what a panda is but if you
give
a picture I could definitely predict if
it's a panda or not which would be a bit
that's fine I mean that's the sensible
way of thinking about it and it just
depends where you personally feel that
your risks are in my experience this is
a triangle that's out there and
personally yes I'm on this side of the
spectrum I'm mostly interested in say
doing Bayesian convolutional networks on
time series that might be correlated so
exactly this intersection that's where
I'm gonna be but even I use something to
use tactics from here so my conclusion
is please give this a bit of you know
some attention because it's a very fine
field you might learn some stuff from it
but from if I'm gonna send you guys off
with any lesson just never let your
school get in the way of your education
there's three schools out there the
truth was always somewhere in the middle
thanks and there's an appendix with
extra probabilities stuff Thanks